Well, church, uh, we, we had, uh,
two baptisms in the first service
and now we have three in this service,
and so we're super thankful for that.
You just might look around and see all the students in the
back there coming
to celebrate Landry Smith who's being baptized today.
God's been working on her heart for a while and camp
and school and church stuff,
and especially at home, just thankful for
what God has done is she shared that
with our student ministry team
and talked with us about her faith in Christ.
And so because of that profession of faith land, I get
to baptize you in the name of the Father, son,
and Holy Spirit,
praise God.